guilbeault parlant du discours du trône
parlons de la portion environnementale
du discours du trône qui est ambitieux
on vous le dit le gouvernement mettra
immédiatement en place un plan qui
permettra de surpasser les objectifs
climatiques du canada pour 2030 et vous
voulez aussi rendre le canada
carboneutre aussi d'ici 2050
comment est-ce que c'est réaliste de
mettre ça en place en contexte actuel le
contexte de pandémie qui ralentit à peu
près tout nous pensons que c'est qu'il
faut qu'il faut le faire
nous nous étions engagés lors de la
dernière campagne électorale et le
premier ministre le dit à plusieurs
reprises bien sure you lie à la crise de
la colline mais la crise climatique ne
s'efface pas pour autant on a vu mais
c'est une complexité d'avancé complexité
de plus la wii je pense qu'il faut en
fait il faut s'occuper de crise en même
temps c'est vrai et c'est pas facile
mais je pense qu'il ya des choses qui
vont faire de part et d'autre qui vont
nous aider alors plus on va être capable
de lutter sur la crise climatique plus
ça va nous aider sur son sur la crise
sur la crise la commune donc en même
temps il ya des premiers ministres comme
monsieur kenny qui me disait la semaine
dernière à l'émission on a déjà de la
difficulté si vous ajoutez des cochons
des épaisseurs de règles en matière
environnementale on va suffoquer nous
comment ont réussi à joindre les deux je
pense que dans le cas de l'alberta
c'est pas les miss politique quelconque
mesure du fédéral qui fait que les
choses vont pas bien c'est
l'effondrement des prix du pétrole qui
ont qui ont précédé l'arrivée de la
crise l'absence d'impact sur leurs
économies et peut pas le nier des
mesures des mesures des règles
environnementales plus sévères qui
s'appliquera cette industrie là aurait
un impact encore plus dévastateurs sur
leurs économies
je parlerai pas non je pas d'accord si
on regarde par exemple ou au canada est
ce que le développement des énergies
renouvelables est le plus important
c'est pas au québec ces points notariaux
pas en colombie-britannique et en
alberta
c'est là où il se fait le plus
d'investissements la compagnie de warren
buffett berkshire hathaway a investi
dans l'un des plus gros projets de parcs
éoliens en alberta il ya de
l'investissement dans le solaire c'est
c'est vraiment la pépinière présentement
au canada
alors c'est vrai qu'une partie de
l'économie qui vote qui voit pas bien
celles reliées au pétrole mais il ya
tout un autre volet de l'économique
en train de se développer en alberta et
donc pour des raisons qui m'échappent le
premier ministre kenny refuse refuse de
parler des investissements très
importants qui sont faits mais c'est
vrai que le pétrole ça va pas bien et
selon les projections des experts ça va
continuer une pause allait bien il le
risque pour le canada c'est que si on ne
prend pas le virage là nous allons
manquer nous allons manquer le
développement des technologies la
création d'emplois dans les secteurs de
l'économie du 21e c'est pour ça que les
mots pétrole le mot gaz était pas dans
discours du trône de mercredi je sais
pas pourquoi spécifiquement c'est mon
lait n'y était pas mais ce que c'est on
n'a qu'à regarder ce qui se passe au
niveau du transport par exemple nous
nous en nous nous dirigeons de plus en
plus vers un transport électrifié c'est
vrai dans le code des voitures et on
voit qu'une annonce très intéressante
qui s'en vient en ontario pour la
construction de la plus grande usine de
fabrication de voitures électriques en
amérique du nord
on le voit dans toutes sortes de
domaines du transport aussi dans le
transport scolaire
l'entreprise québécoise lyon qui vendait
des autobus scolaires partout en
amérique du nord et même ailleurs qui
est vraiment un succès alors il faut il
faut aider pour pour la porte pour la
survie des emplois dans le secteur de
l'automobile par exemple dans toute la
chaîne d'approvisionnement il faut aider
le secteur à 30 ce virage là là il ya
vraiment un impératif à la fois
environnementale mais économiques et
liées aux emplois de prendre ce virage
là et lakovic fait en sorte que ça
complique un peu les choses mais il faut
le faire malgré tout ce qu'il bourges
petit retour dans le temps il ya un an
jour pour jour vous étiez à la marche
sur le climat pour le climat avec votre
premier ministre avec greta tout de même
qu'à montréal
qu'est ce qui a changé de club mais
évidemment la cause il nous a pris
toutes et tous par par surprise mais ce
qui va changer c'est ce que fais tu nous
faisons toujours face à une crise
climatique et que le demi million de
personnes qui avaient dans les rues de
montréal qui nous demandaient d'agir la
thuyone on nous demande encore d'agir
bien sûr il ya beaucoup de gens qui sont
préoccupés par par la pandémie par par
l'aco vide d'où le fait que nous avons
mis en place des mesures très
importantes au cours des derniers mois
pour aider les gens à passer à travers
ces beaucoup de gens qui sont déçus de
voir que malgré toute cette bonne
volonté belvaux discours il s'est pas
passé grand chose depuis une pandémie ou
pas par des milles avant la pandémie
ça n'a pas bougé non mes mains et entre
l'élection et le début de la pandémie on
a eu à peu près trois mois pour
gouverner alors c'est sûr qu'il n'y a
pas énormément de choses qui ont été
faites jusqu'à maintenant c'est vrai
mais moi je regardais une guerre des
commentaires de mes ex collègues du
milieu environnemental
le réseau action climat qui parlait d'un
discours historique sur la question de
l'environnement
la fondation david suzuki nature canada
tous ces groupes là se sont dit très
heureux de voir le discours du trône
bien sûr maintenant on va devoir livrer
la marchandise parce que le bon et
jusqu'en france pour un projet de loi ce
point budget c'est pas un énoncé de
vision et la vision et les très claire
par contre sur lot où on veut aller et
je pense que c'est ce que les gens ont
aimé entendre y allant de vaudou aussi à
vous vous êtes ministère du patrimoine
canadien vous avez du pain sur la
planche il ya eu une longue consultation
que vous avez menée concernant l'avenir
de la loi sur la radiodiffusion dans le
discours de mercredi on parlait la
fameuse taxe sur les gaffes assurent les
géants du web et a besoin il ya besoin
une nécessité de revoir aussi de tout
l'écosystème de radiodiffusion canada où
est-ce que vous en êtes là dessus et
quand est ce qu'on peut s'attendre
à des gestes concrets sur la question de
la taxation évidemment ça relève de ma
collègue madame frileux nos finances je
suis ministre patrimoine ministre des
finances mais le premier ministre
trudeau la fin 2019 sur les ondes de
radio canada avait annoncé que sur la
question de la taxation
c'était clair pour lui que les géants du
web paierez la tps comme l'ensemble des
entreprises au canada et que ça allait
se faire dans le prochain budget
ce budget là à cause d'un câble n'est
pas encore arrivé il arrivera bientôt
pour moi ça c'est un dossier qui va se
régler assez rapidement sur les
questions il ya deux dossiers sur
lesquels et 1,33 dossier important sur
lequel je travaille autour de la
question des géants du web 1 sur la
refonte de la loi sur la radiodiffusion
pour pau pour que l'on s'assure que les
géants du web contribue à la culture et
aux arts au canada il faut retrouver un
équilibre au niveau de la radiodiffusion
parce que là on a des entreprises
canadiennes comme radio-canada comme
bell comme cogeco qui investissent dans
la culture canadienne et on a des géants
du web qui n'ont aucune obligation mais
pourtant qui font beaucoup d'argent au
canada
nous ce qu'on dit c'est que si vous
bénéficiez du système vous devez y
contribuer également première chose
deuxième chose tout le secteur des
médias les entreprises comme facebook et
google utilise le contenu des médias
canadiens pour générer du trafic sur
leur site font beaucoup d'argent grâce à
ça nous on veut que les médias canadiens
soit compensée de façon équitable c'est
quand ça arrive qu'un bain ce projet de
loi le gie travail avec notamment le
ministre banzio ministre de justice
monsieur l'amitié et quelques mois on a
un projet de loi le premier sur la
radiodiffusion
ce sera déposée d'ici quelques semaines
alors ces choses là vont arriver assez
rapidement
la troisième chose auquel nous voulons
nous attaquer c'est toute la question de
la haine en ligne le discours est nu sur
ceux sur les plateformes on a essayé la
voie de l'autoréglementation on a
demandé à facebook et pouvez vous
contrôlez les choses ou même de toute
évidence ça fonctionne pas alors il
faudra mettre en place une
réglementation pour ça c'est bien beau
merci beaucoup merci beaucoup